hi I have a husband he's nice people I
can know we're very happy we both been
married before and so we know you know
what the secret is can I tell you the
secret the secret is every night before
we go to bed we play this game and it's
called how is this better than our first
marriage he'll say things like you
really get me and I'll say you never
slept with the babysitter but it's
worked we've been married 15 years I
know 15 years isn't that long I'm in
therapy
19 years not that I have the greatest
therapist it's just the longest
relationship I've ever been in so I show
up every week and although I have to
take my therapist is a little strange
she cleans during our sessions is that
normal
normal no she's winged Xing and
swiffering and dusting and I don't
really mind but you know when she
vacuums I think it's a little
inappropriate and I finally spoke up
after all these years I finally said
something I said hey I got a great idea
why do we do this in my house and we'll
actually get something accomplished my
sister who's older than me just started
therapy which is very late for my people
and I I was very supportive I said
that's great you're in therapy she goes
okay but I think I should let you know I
confronted mommy about the lunches and I
said the lunches what lunches she goes
you know the fact that she never made
our lunch said all the lunches
see I would have started with the
beatings he's not that bad it's just my
mother has an entirely different
recollection of my childhood than I do
anybody else had this yes so we were a
family function and my mother was
recounting this adorable story of us
when we were kids and it was a familiar
story but it wasn't us and it wasn't to
like drove her home that hit me I was
like no mommy that wasn't us that was
that was Dawson's Creek oh I told my
therapist that I want to go on an
antidepressant and she said okay what do
you have in mind and I said whatever
Melania Trump is taking because that I
have two kids I have a daughter from my
first marriage and then I have a son
from this one little bit of an age
difference between my kids I I had my
daughter when I was 22 and I had my son
when I was 42 yes you're shocked imagine
how my daughter felt do my daughter
tells people behind my back my mother is
such a control freak she had her own
grandchild
my my son was very upset when he heard
about this and he he said mommy but
you'll see when I have kids you'll still
be there there grandma right and I was
like sure if I remember who you are but
I wanted I want to be there I'm trying
to take care of myself and I've been
going to doctors matter of fact just
recently I was at the doctor you know
for a regular lady checkup and and I I
saw what my insurance paid the doctor
$17 could you imagine $17 the doctor got
to just look under the hood I mean how
is the doctors supposed to stay in
business I mean I can understand if
we're talking about a 22 year old you
know like then ariana grande's lotus
blossom or a Dakota Fanning's
bird-of-paradise then 17 dollars you
know what is it a look at it's probably
still under warranty but this this you
need a trained eye for this you know
they don't make parts for this anymore
$17 is not gonna cut it you needed an
expert when this came off the assembly
line bumpers could still take a hit at
25 miles an hour I'm just saying this is
what you call a classic it's a classic
some people call it a collector's item
my husband calls it a collector's item
I'm gonna get it appraised I'm thinking
of getting it appraised I'm gonna take
the Antiques Roadshow what do you got
there okay 1964 model V how many owners
there were two owners okay there were
other drivers
[Applause]
you